- So both of you are
mothers of black sons.
So what kind of conversations
are taking place
in your homes right now?
- Ah well, I mean it's
a normal conversation,
a conversation that's
of course been going on
since the beginning of time
and even from the days
that we first got here.
It's a conversation of being careful.
That when you go out, be kind.
You think about in 1800's, you know,
don't make eye contact.
There's always the conversation.
Every generation it's different.
Now, and we say, you know,
be nice to the police.
My brothers were told, say "yes sir."
But now it doesn't matter.
Now it's just, be
careful, do what you can.
Have all your ducks in a row.
The conversations very,
my son is nine years old
so I was hoping that this conversation
wouldn't be around any more.
But every year I see that I
have to have the conversation
and my son said to me
when I told him about
what happened to George Floyd, he said
"Am I gonna die one day?"
- Oh my gosh!
- It's a hard thing being you know-
- It really, no, no no, go ahead.
I was just gonna say, but
I just wanna say this,
what I want to say to people is,
my son is like your son.
Our children are all the same.
We're mothers.
They grow up to be men but
don't be afraid of my son.
Don't be afraid of me.
We are people, we are all people
and we are all just trying
to raise our families
and have good lives.
Go ahead Sherry, say what you gotta say.
- It's the most ridiculous
thing I think though
that you have to say that.
- Kelly it's really, it's just
like Kim said, to piggy-back.
It's awful that we're still
experiencing the same thing
that people went through
in the 50's and the 60's
when they were marching.
And to have to tell our sons,
we're black mothers so our
prayer is very different,
to tell our sons how to
survive just to make it home
is very anguishing and it's devastating.
And just like Kim, my son likes the WWE,
he watches Nickelodeon, he's
got a great sense of humor
and he just wants a girlfriend
and that's just like anybody else's son.
But to know that somebody
won't get to the core
of how beautiful he is
because of his skin color
is really frightening to me.
And, you know, we just call for people to
speak out against racism
and speak out when you
see something wrong.
Speak out.
And also, there's things
in the rooms that you hear
that Kim and I won't hear
because we're two black women
and we just ask for people
when you say, what can we do?
Speak out and say, where
are the people of color
behind the scenes that
can make a difference
on even TV
so that our sons can grow up
and be and do what they love
like everybody else's children.
- No, and it's the same thing I think with
even police brutality.
It's like, hey, okay, there
are great cops out there
but you're not great if
you're just standing by.
Like, you need to say something.
Like you have to call people
out and, it's gotta change.
And so anyway, that's why I love,
I know it's not uncomfortable for me
but I know it can be
uncomfortable for some people,
especially in the spotlight,
but I really appreciate
you being very honest
and vulnerable and truthful
because I think that's the only way
people are gonna hear you,
you know, whoever you are
wanting to get your message out.
So, anyway, thank you for
discussing that with me.
I really appreciate it.